je savais qu'il savait
qu'à chaque heure
de chaque jour je le pensais robert
n'est pas mort au camp de concentration
depuis l'arrestation de robert reste
fragilisée ont cherché à tout contenu
jusqu'à femmes dotées c'est ça
j'ai rencontré le flic qui arrêtait
robert le salon des sports
je suis très flatté d'être assis à la
même table jamais fait mais je ne suis
pas ici pour parler littérature vous
savez bien je suis là pour parler de mon
mari pour votre colis je pense que je
peux faire
merci
je peux pour toi tout bon il faut que je
fasse attention je vois ce qu'il essaie
de faire connaître cet homme qui se sert
de moi alors même que je crois me servir
de lui
si vous m'aider à le retrouver je france
au retour vers soient pas des portugais
commencent à déporter
danone
pour mépriser ils ont comme vous savez
plus de gens comme moi
elles volent à plus de tâches et des
rentes est notre boulot